- Ils sont des dizaines de
milliers de patients orphelins
à enfin voir la lumière
au bout du tunnel, parfois
après des années d'attente.
Selon Québec, plus de
288 000 patients sont désormais
inscrits auprès d'un groupe de
médecine de famille, dépassant
l'objectif de 250 000 personnes
prises en charge que
s'était fixé Québec.
Mais dans quel délai
les patients auront-ils
accès à une consultation?
Dr MARC-ANDRÉ AMYOT, Fédération
des médecins omnipraticiens Qc
- Les médecins offrent de
la disponibilité rapidement
à leur clientèle inscrite,
donc dans un délai
de 0-36-72 heures.
- Pourtant, plus de
814 000 Québécois sont toujourss
à un médecin de famille.
Ils étaient 480 000 lorsque
la CAQ est arrivée au pouvoir
en 2018, une hausse de 69 %
en 4 ans.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- À l'époque, il y avait des
gens qui s'inscrivaient pas sur
la liste parce qu'ils étaient
tellement convaincus
qu'ils auraient pas
de médecin de famille.
- Pour Félix-Antoine Gingras,
c'est le parcours du combattant.
Il attend depuis 6 ans qu'on lui
assigne un médecin de famille,
tout comme son père,
dont la santé est
particulièrement fragile.
FÉLIX-ANTOINE GINGRAS
- J'ai 27 ans, je suis en pleine
forme et c'est peut-être moinsge
mon père, qui a plus de 60 ans,
qui a une santé qui est peut-
être plus précaire et même,
en ce moment, il a le cancer
du poumon et il a toujours pas
de médecin de famille
attitré à lui, là.
Aujourd'hui, c'est pas...
son besoin en médecin de famille
est peut-être moins grave
étant donné qu'il a un problème
très, très grave qui demande
- Le prochain objectif
est d'avoir un total de
500 000 personnes prises
en charge en mars 2023.
Pour l'atteindre, Québec
un guichet d'accès
à la première ligne que
devront contacter ces patients.
- Ils vont appeler à ce numéro
de téléphone, et là, il y a
une infirmière qui va
les évaluer et qui va...trier lr
les orienter vers le meilleur
professionnel pour répondre
à la problématique.
- Mais avec un déficit
de 1000 médecins de famille,
selon le Dr Amyot, cette cib
demeure un défi de taille.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.